مهمات قتاليه خطيره يقوم بها طيار
المروحيات التابعونا للجيش الاوكراني في
حربهم ضد روسيا
الجزء الاصعب هو الاستعداد للمهمه واتخاذ
قرارات بشان كيفيه التصرف اثناء الرحله من
اي اتجاه ستنتقل الى الهدف وتطلق النار
نحن نحسب كل شيء مع تواصل مركز قيادتنا مع
مركز قياده القوات البريه على خط المواجهه
للتنسيق
بالاعتماد فقط على مهاراتهم وما تعلموه
على مدار السنوات الخمس الماضيه مع غياب
التدريب يضطروا هؤلاء الطيارون الى
التحليق على ارتفاع منخفض بشكل خطير
باتجاه بخموت الواقعه شرق اوكرانيا وعند
الاقتراب من هدفهم يجب ان يرتفعوا فجاه
ويطلقون وابلا من الصواريخ قبل ان ياخذوا
منعطفا حادا للعوده الى قاعدتهم
[موسيقى]
هو طيران اقل من مستوى التضاريس حتى لا
تكون المروحيه مرئيه في انظمه رادار
الروسيه وحتى لا يعلم بقدومنا حتى اللحظه
الاخيره هذا سيمنعه من الاتصال بين
الوحدات
بعض الطيارين الاوكراني يقولون انه لو
كانت هناك مروحيات اكثر تطورا فسيكون من
الممكن تحقيق المزيد من المهام الناجحه
لقصف مواقع الجيش الروسي
اذا كانت لدينا مروحيات سنحقق المزيد من
المهام الناجحه حيث تم انشاؤها لضرب
الدبابات
الحرب في اوكرانيا اثار التساؤلات حول دور
المروحيات المحدود بعض الشيء وذلك لامتلاك
كلا الطرفين لمنظومات دفاع جوي جيده وفق
محللين تستخدم اوكرانيا غالبا المروحيات
في هجماتها السريعه حيث تطلق المروحيه
الهجوميه صواريخها دفعه واحده وتنسحب
بسرعه وبالتالي لكلا الطرفين اصبح
الاهتمام اكثر بالطائرات المسيره لمهام
الاستطلاع والمراقبه والهجوم لقله خسائرها
وتكلفتها ايضا رشا خياط العربيه